[MUSIC]
When I was two years old, my parents
noticed that I was not speaking.
Quickly thereafter,
the doctors diagnosed me as deaf.
For the next 12 years of my life,
I learned to speak.
I spent many Sunday afternoons with
my mother on the bedroom carpet and
she'd teach me words.
We called these sessions words.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Basically,
we would sit there and she would teach
me words and I would never forget this
story that my mother told me
about the first word I learned.
It was the word up.
She'd hold me in her arms and
she'd carry me up, and down the stairs.
And she said to me, Caroline,
we're going up, up we go, up.
All my mom's friends and family thought
she was crazy taking on this grand
project, but I want to say the word up.
I see how she opened and closed her mouth,
up and closed with a pop.
Finally, she would take my hand and
place it on her throat and
I feel through the vibrations what
kind of sound she was trying to make.
Finally, at the age 2.5,
I said the word back to her, up.
When my mom heard these words, she was so
overjoyed to cry tears of happiness.
I ask her, why did you teach me to speak
instead of teaching me sign language?
And she said, Caroline,
it's because I wanted you to
connect with anyone in this world.
I wanted you to introduce yourself and
say, hello.
I want you to stand in front of
an audience and express yourself, and
your ideas.
Not a day goes by that I'm not grateful
for her teaching how to speak.
The ability to connect with
anyone is such a privilege.
I'm able to connect with anyone I can.
And through the path of
learning how to speak,
I've grown to learn about
the power of the word.
I'm going to share a few short stories
with you about the power of the word.
By the time I was in second grade, I had
slowly, but surely built up my vocabulary.
However, it was a little
on the simple side.
So I had a plan.
After school,
I looked to read the dictionary.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was a little tedious.
>> But I kept reading it.
And then the next day I go into class and
I say, these very smart and
complex words and
I thought I was so impressive.
But the teacher would come over and
say Caroline,
do you know why you're using these words?
Are they proud of you?
But you're not using them correctly.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was embarrassed in the moment and
it's funny now.
But when I reflect back on it, I realize
sure, I used smart and complex words.
But they didn't understand
what I was saying.
And I have found time and
time again by using simple words,
you can connect so
much more powerfully with anyone.
By being simple, you are not dumbing down.
You are being smarter with your time and
your words.
Be powerful by being simple.
Words allowed us to connect with others,
but they also allow us
to imagine the future.
About two years ago, I was skiing
down the slopes of New Zealand and
I took a wrong turn and snap.
I broke three out of four
of my knee ligaments.
It was a very serious injury and
I immediately went into surgery.
As I'm exiting the fog anesthesia, I see
this surgeon staring at me with a very
serious face and she says, Caroline,
that was a very serious injury.
You're going to have to work very hard
to walk againand I remember in that
moment thinking I'm deaf already.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My life
is hard enough as it is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But he was right, it was really hard.
I would go to physical therapy
not make any progress.
I was barely able to bend my knee.
And slowly as the days went by,
as the weeks went by, fear crept into me.
What if I never walk again?
Finally, after a lot of resistance,
I met with a sports psychologist.
Her name was Linda and
she would sit me down and she'd say, okay,
let's close our eyes.
Let's imagine that you're walking again.
I'm a little bit of a skeptical person.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm like what is this exercise?
>> But she would walk me through.
She'd say, okay,
let's imagine you sitting and getting up.
Imagine you walking.
Imagine you running,
feeling the grass on your ankles.
So I did.
Every day, I wake up and imagine
myself doing all of these things and
what happened afterwards is amazing.
I made rapid progress
in my physical therapy.
I started walking again,
I was able to run and everyone was amazed.
They didn't understand what was happening,
except me.
I knew that a surgeon had healed
my body with the operation.
But Linda, the sport psychologist
had healed my body with words.
I was able to visualize the future.
She gave me a seed of a dream.
When you think about how you use words,
you can either address the hardships.
You had a really bad injury or
you can address the future and
address, and make up a vision.
You can do it for
yourselves or for others.
Be powerful by being inspirational.
My last story is a love story.
I love to write love letters.
I have a whole stack of them on my desk,
but I've never really sent them.
Because I didn't want to creep
out the person I was dating.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Until I finally met the one last
year who I wanted to send the letter to.
I wrote it all in one go and
I sent it off, I didn't hear anything.
I was terrified.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But finally, I got response back and
it was beautiful.
And so in once said to me, being in love
feels like when you've lost everything,
but then it's been returned to you and
that's how I felt in that moment.
[COUGH] A week later,
I'm at this person's house and
I see in the corner a waste basket and
it has all the drafts of my letter.
So I decided to do what any
mature person would do.
I respected this person's privacy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No.
>> I obviously read them all.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm embarrassed to say that, but
I read them all and I had to learn
something really interesting.
I'm reading through these drafts and
I notice something strange.
There were all these really tender and
vulnerable words that were crossed out.
But when I compared it to
the final letter I received,
I noticed that my final letter
only had those tender and
vulnerable words and that's where
the beauty of your letter came from.
Be powerful by saying the lines
that you want to cross out.
How do you measure a life?
You measure a life through words.
Words are like seeds.
When we say them,
they float through the air.
They can remain a seed or
they can grow into something beautiful.
Words can distance or they can connect.
Words can harm or they can heal and
words can transform lives
as they have done for me.
All of you, as you go through this life,
think about how we
use the power of the word to connect,
inspire and to lift up.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]